Hello, everybody. Welcome to a new episode of the
day host, Ricardo Loops. And today I'm joined by
Doctor Christian Hart. He is a professor of Psychology
at Texas Women's University where he is the Director
of the Psychological Science Program, as well as the
director of the Human Deception Laboratory. His research explores
the behavioral cues of deception, pathological, lying, lying within
relationships, lying, morality and the factors that influence decisions
to be honest or deceptive. And today we are
focusing mostly on his two books, Pathological Lying Theory,
Research and Practice and his latest one, big liars.
What psychological science tells us about lying and how
you can avoid being duped. So Dr Hart, welcome
to the show. It's a big pleasure to everyone.
Uh Thanks for having me, Ricardo. It's a great
pleasure for me to be here. I'm a big
fan of your podcast.
Well, thank you so much. So, get, let's get
right into it. And I would like to start
perhaps with a basic question. So what is a
lie exactly? I mean, since you approach, I guess
lying and honesty from a psychological viewpoint, uh what
counts really as a lie here. Uh
WE define lying as a, a communication that's intended
to convince someone of something that we know is
untrue. So, and, and, and when I say communication,
we, we usually mean uh the spoken word but
also obviously the written word. Um BUT we also
communicate using gestures and using silence. Um So any
uh natural communication that's that we use to try
to impart um some information on someone else that
we know to be untrue.
And do we know before we get into lying
itself, do we have good enough data to tell
how honest people are in general or not?
Well, the way that we study dishonesty and lying
is, um, is primarily through self report. So we
ask people and, you know, there's the inherent problem
in there when we're asking people to self report
about their behavior. Are they giving us accurate information,
especially on a topic like dishonesty? And so we,
we try to, um, you know, set the stage,
uh, such that people will be, um, straightforward when
they're telling us about their patterns of lying. And
one of the ways we do that is we,
um, have them give us that information anonymously. So
typically through anonymous online surveys. So there's no one
judging them. So there's no real incentive to, to,
um, to be dishonest. Uh, WE also normalize lying
like we'll usually, uh, set the stage by, by
telling people, most people lie fairly regularly. Uh, ALMOST
everyone lies at some point. And so now we
want to know about your patterns of lying and,
and we, we have some evidence that when people
self report about their lying, they're actually giving us
accurate information because uh you know, there are, there
are uh experimental techniques where we could ask people
whether they lie a little or lie a lot
and they'll tell us and, and then we can
bring them into the laboratory and set up contrived
situations where they can, um, either be honest or
they can lie for a financial reward. And what
we find is people who say I tend to
lie a lot. They tend to actually lie in
those laboratory situations. And then people who say they're
particularly honest tend not to lie in those situations.
So we have some validity checks that suggest those,
uh, self report measures are, are probably fairly accurate.
Mhm. So, I would imagine that pretty much everyone
lies some of the time and, and I'm not
saying I'm not talking here about big massive deceptions
or anything like that. I mean, it's mostly, I
would imagine like small white lies that don't cause
damage at all, I would imagine. But let me
actually ask you about that. So, should we, first
of all, should we expect the people to be
honest most of the time? And when they are
dishonest? I mean, what are some of the most
common ways people lie? Really?
Yeah. And so we, we do find that most
people are mostly on most of the time. And
so, one of the ways that, that we assess
lying in, in our laboratory is we, we ask
people, how many lies have you told in the
past 24 hours? And the majority of people say
zero and, and of those people who say they
have told a lie, it tends to be pretty
minimal, one lie or two lies. Um But we
do have this subset of people that, that lie
and extraordinarily uh lie extraordinarily uh frequently. Um And
when we look at why people lie, you're right.
You know, these tend not to be big lies.
Most of the uh reasons that people give for
lying are to avoid shame and embarrassment. So they're
lying to save face essentially. And um and, and
so people's deception tends not to be malicious. Uh
uh Most of the lying tends to be uh
protecting themselves and people lie for privacy sake. Um
People also tell lies just to smooth over social
interactions. And so, you know, when I come into
the office and one of my colleagues says, how
are you doing today? Even if I'm not doing
that that great, I'll say I'm doing fine. And
it's because neither of us wants to have a
difficult conversation about my personal life struggles at that
moment. You know, so we, we tell these uh
these lies pretty regularly just to allow uh social
interactions to proceed smoothly
and I might be wrong here. But isn't it
also the case that uh a big chunk of
the time when we lie? It's not actually uh
uh really a straight uh straight out lying but
mostly like omitting some information that people do not
ask us directly. But perhaps we might think. Oh,
ok. So perhaps if I were 100% honest, I
should also make deciding not to do that something
like that. Right.
Yeah, that's, that's what we find is that, um,
if most people wanna avoid giving honest answers, they
will use the most morally defensible strategy possible. And,
and the, the, the easiest one is just to
avoid a topic entirely so different, then I don't
need to talk to you about these, uh, unpleasant
things that I don't wanna, um, that I don't
wanna discuss other ways that, that we can answer
or respond dishonestly is by minimizing, um, by using
vague language. And so most people will only use
an outright lie as is the, the strategy of
last resort because an outright lie is in most
people's minds kind of morally indefensible. If you're caught
in a lie, it, it, it has some big,
um, social repercussions and reputational repercussions. And so most
of us will try to, um, find these, uh,
uh, less grievous, uh, uh, strategies for being dishonest.
Yeah. Basically some small ways of circumventing, uh, total
honesty. Right. Exactly. Exactly. Ok. So, a and using
or referring to the title of one of your
books, the most recent one. Who are these big
liars, what characterizes them?
Well, when we, we've studied thousands of people in
our studies and what we find consistently, as I
mentioned earlier is most people are pretty honest, but
there's this small subset that, that lies um extraordinarily.
And so when we're talking about big liars in
the book, we talk about really kind of two
groups of people, people who lie very frequently. Um
But also um people who tell maybe fewer lies
but lies that have massive consequences. And so when
we look at the types of people who tend
to lie very frequently, we see some patterns. Um
ONE is they turn um lying kind of peaks
in late adolescence for most people and then declines
across adulthood. And so younger people tend to lie
more than older people. Um We've looked at gender
differences and what we find is that men and
women don't really lie differentially as far as frequency,
men. I mean, there's a slight difference but it's,
it's like 4% difference. It's pretty uh minor. But
when we look at people who lie a lot,
it's predominantly men. And so when we look at
those people who probably, you know, 10 or more
lies a day, uh the men, uh definitely outnumber
um the women. And then there's other patterns that
we see um in personality traits. For example, we
see that um, self esteem is associated with lying.
So people with low self esteem tend to lie
considerably more than people with higher self esteem. And
that kind of tracks with, um, you know, some
of the things I was talking about earlier is
people often lie out of a sense of shame
or embarrassment, things like that. Um And then we
also see some personality traits like the the dark
triad personality traits like Machiavellian is and, and psychopathy.
So people who are kind of generally kind of
nasty, manipulative people use dishonesty, um, more often than
people who don't, uh, have those personality traits. And
then, you know, so, so those are some of
the factors that are associated with being, uh, prolific
liars or big liars.
Ok. So let's go through some of the differences
there, break them down a little bit further. So,
uh, you mentioned there, for example that, uh, generally
speaking, there's not a big difference in the rates
of lying between men and women, but among the
big liars, most of them seem to be male.
So, is there any explanation to for that?
Well, when we, uh, when we look at, um,
how some of these big liars operate, some of
them are, um, more, uh, manipulative and they will
kind of callously take advantage of others. And those
traits are, are much more common in men than
they are in women. Um, SORT of status seeking
is much higher in males um, and so it's,
it's possible that those are actually the underlying traits
that are, uh, more related to the lying rather
than the, you know, the biological sex itself. It's
these, um, these traits that probably are to a
certain degree socialized and probably to a certain degree,
there's something, you know, different in our underlying biology
that gives rise to these traits where males, more
than females tend to outright, um, use outright manipulation
as a technique to get ahead in the world.
And what about uh some general biological differences? I
mean, are there any notable biological differences between big
liars and the general population?
There's really limited research on this topic. Um There
is um there has been some research looking at
um a gray matter and white matter in the
brain. So, gray matter are essentially the the neurons
and white matter are the pathways the myelinated axons.
And um there's some research suggesting that people who
lie extraordinarily have uh more white matter to gray
matter ratio than, than non prolific liars in the
frontal lobe of the brain. So this is the
frontal lobe of the brain is, you know, one
of the parts of the brain that are really
essential for executive processes like um you know, plans
making and things like that. And so there's been
some speculation in the literature that um these differences
and executive functioning processes due to differences in underlying
biology might be relevant to these patterns that we
see with some people lying less and some people
lying more. Um, THERE'S also evidence that dishonesty is
a heritable trait. So it's maybe it's coded in
our genes to a certain extent. Um, AND so
the heritability is about 30% which means about may,
maybe about 30% of the variability that we have
and people's tendency to be honest is related to
our underlying genes. And, um, and certainly there's heritability
for things like, um, like psychopathy and just that
tendency to, you know, take advantage of others without
having much remorse about it. So, so those, that's
probably about the extent that we can say anything,
um, definitive about the underlying biology of being a
big liar.
By the way, when it comes to possibly thinking
about honesty as a trait as a personality trait,
I guess in this case, does it relate in
any way to the exec personality traits? Because one
of them is honesty, humility. Is there any relationship
there or, or not?
Oh, sure. And that's one of the ways that
we assess, you know, honesty and dishonesty is using
the Hexaco traits. Um, WE have a few other
measures of honesty and dishonesty. But, but, um, yeah,
that, that broad personality trait, um, uh, is, um,
is a principal measure that we use.
And what about culture and the context where people
live in? Does that also play a role in
shaping the differences between big liars and the rest
of the people.
Uh, IT, it does. And we can, you know,
when we think about culture, we can think about
the, the very local level, like the, the family
that someone lives in. There's great variability there. And,
um, so I, I teach a seminar on Deception.
I talk with my students about the families they
grow up in and there's, there's a wide range
of, uh, of, um, styles, uh, and attitudes toward
honesty and dishonesty that we see where now some
students who talk about their parents have raised them
and told them if you can get ahead by
lying, you should, you know, so they're really almost
encouraging. Um LYING is a strategy. And we see
that in families where um the parents are very
punitive, um the Children tend to lie a lot
more, uh actually in families where uh a person
just has siblings, they tend to lie a lot
more. So there's something about sibling dynamics that might
be relevant. But if we look at culture more
broadly, what we do see is that, for example,
across countries, there's different attitudes about dishonesty and honesty
and it's kind of uh really domain specific. And
so for example, in some countries and certain um
occupational fields, it's accepted to be dishonest and not
in other fields. And so, but very broadly, yeah,
we do see um across countries, when we ask
people about their tendency to lie in some countries,
people lie a lot more than in others. And
it seems to track, uh along with, um with
broad social organizations. So in countries where there's a
lot of corruption, for example, the individuals in those
countries tend to lie a lot
more. And I guess that there are also cultures
where, I mean, you're not allowed to express certain
ideas or say certain things out of politeness and
courtesy, I guess, like, for example, Japan and places
like that where there are things that people really
feel very, very uneasy saying, but not, not, I,
I'm not sure if that's actual dishonesty because it's
done out of politeness, courtesy and stuff like that.
But I mean, perhaps from our point of view
it would be dishonest in a way. Right.
Yeah, sure. You know, the, the, the taboos, um,
uh, vary considerably from one culture to another. And
so in countries where there are a lot of
taboo topics, you'd expect there to be a lot
of, um, less than fully honest communication. And we
can actually see that historically in western Europe, um,
how honesty and dishonesty has been treated and how
it's been interpreted has changed considerably over like the
past 500 years. Um, AND, uh, where at certain
times it would be considered deeply, deeply offensive to
be honest. And so it was expected or encouraged
to be dishonest. And we can see that even
in, like, in the United States right now that,
you know, Children are are taught not to uh
express their true feelings about a gift they've received.
For example, if they receive a gift that they
don't like, they're, they're uh indoctrinated into this uh
style of, of acting as if they do like
it and commenting about how much they enjoy it
when they actually don't.
Mhm. Does uh this kind of big lying, have
anything to do with personal philosophies?
Sure. Um WE, we uh have a, a scale
or a measurement that we use, um, fairly often
that assesses people's attitudes toward lying and it asks
questions like, you know, it's ok to lie sometimes
and people strongly agree or strongly disagree. And what
we see is that there's pretty wide variability in
people's attitudes about honesty and the importance of honesty.
And some people see honesty is absolutely essential and
they fret that they're not being honest enough and
other people have a more cavalier attitude about honesty
or dishonesty and feel like dishonesty is necessary and
there's nothing particularly wrong with it. And so they
are much more apt to lie.
And, I mean, why is it, what motivates these
big liars? Exactly. I mean, why do they lie
so prolifically and monumentally sometimes, at least
there's a lot of, uh, different reasons why people
lie lying is really just a strategy that we
use to, you know, achieve, uh, you know, that
the outcomes that we want to experience. And so
in some cases, you know, people are wanting to
facilitate social relationships. And so they lie in order
to, you know, bond with people or feel a
sense of connection with people. Um IN other cases,
people are trying to gain a financial advantage or
a power advantage. And so they're lying for those
reasons. So, um you know, the, the motivations for
lying are as, as varied as the motivations for
doing anything we do in the world. Um And
so, you know, it's really kind of hard to
talk about why people lie or what the motivations
are because it's simply a tool that people use.
You know, and, and we, we have a, a
lot of psychological manipulation tools in our toolbox that
help us achieve our goals. And at the end
of the day, lying is just one of those.
So getting into another possible aspect of what leads
big liars to become a big liar. So, uh
is there anything about uh developmental psychology? I mean,
their childhood development that is special or not?
Well, we see that um patterns of lying emerge
early in life. And so in developmental psychology studies,
we see that most Children will start lying between
the ages of two and three and they're usually
not very good at it, they fumble around, they're
not very convincing. Um Yeah, and, but as they
get older, by the time Children are five or
six, they're pretty good at, at telling lies that
completely convince their parents for example. Um And so
the trajectories that we see is that most Children
lie more and more as they get older until
they reach adolescence. Um But then we see this
kind of break in the trajectories where most, for
most people, their lying tends to, um start to
decline at that point. And one of the reasons
is that there are pretty harsh, uh, social and
reputational consequences for being known as a liar. And
so we've probably all had experiences where we've been
caught in a lie. And so people start to
learn that there are more uh socially productive ways
to get what we want other than lying. And
so that, that trajectory is they tend to um
lie less. But for some Children, that trajectory just
uh keeps on in, in an upward direction. And
so, uh we can start to see these patterns
of who are going to be the big liars
and who aren't pretty early on when we look
at like pathological liars and we interview them and
we ask them, you know, when their lying first
became really problematic in their lives, for the vast
majority of them is during adolescence,
a and in the book, you talk about different
types of liars, like for example, storytellers, exaggerators, pathological
liars. And we'll come back to the pathological liars
specifically later on in our conversation and also psychopath.
So, uh are these all different kinds of big
liars? And if so what distinguishes them from one
another.
Well, the, uh, the, the, they are all liars
and, and they're, yeah, I'd say they're different types
and essentially there are different motivations for them all.
Um, THE storytellers and exaggerators. These are people who
are primarily, uh, telling lies because they like the
positive attention that comes their way when they're telling
these exaggerated outrageous stories. So, you know, I, I
grew up, uh, down the street from a person
who told, told wild stories all the time and
I think everyone knew that they were alive, but
they were just so outrageous that we couldn't turn
away. And so, uh so I think some people,
some storytellers uh that is their motivation is that,
that warm glow of attention when they're, when they're
um saying these outrageous things, um uh path, uh
the psychopaths. On the other hand, these are people
that, you know, callously and remorselessly use others and,
and take advantage of others to get what they
want. And so their motivation is to treat other
people as just mere objects or pawns in their
game to get what they want in the world.
And so they have a much more selfish and
self serving ambitions and goals and uh that disregard
of the, the rights and welfare of others. And
so, you know, you can kind of see the,
the big distinction there. But then I, as I
mentioned earlier, we also have people who lie considerably,
um because they they believe themselves to be inadequate.
And so they're, you know, have this um painfully
low self esteem where they feel like they're just
never measuring up. And the only way they can
feel good about themselves is to present a false
version of themselves to the rest of
the world. A and so I, I mean, there
are in the book, you mentioned several different occupations
where we find some big liars, but before getting
into the occupations themselves, le legitimate occupations in this
case, what about scam artists? Is there anything special
about them?
You know? Uh I, I don't know if there's
anything special about them, although they, they tend to
have psychopathic traits that is, they, they tend to
not have a lot of empathic regard for others.
Um BUT they, they also are really good at
justifying their bad behavior and um and we're all
good at justifying our bad behavior, but they tend
to be pretty exceptional at it where they tend
to have a philosophy or a belief that uh
what they're doing isn't really all that bad. And
so I'm not really harming someone because they have
plenty of money or they would do the exact
same thing to me if they could. Therefore, it's
fine for me to do it to them. And
so when we look at um and scam artists
and, and other criminals for that matter, they tend
to be pretty adept at finding justifications for their
own behavior. I think most of us do that
to a certain degree. But we, we get to
a line where we eventually have this self-recognition that
I'm being a bad person. I'm being the type
of person I don't wanna be and it prevents
us from, from carrying out too many um uh
too many awful things.
A and so there are certain occupations that you
talk about in the book where people, uh I
mean, there are sanctioned lies there uh or some
frequent sanctioned lies like for example, in the case
of lawyers, doctors and politicians. So, uh I mean,
is it the case that perhaps in these kinds
of occupations, we find a higher proportion of uh
quote unquote big liars than in the general population.
And uh and if so why
we, we do and I guess I don't wanna
lump all these occupations in together when talking about
this. Uh YOU know, for example, when we, when
we look at uh uh physicians, um most of
them report that they're not fully honest with their
patients. And so they'll do things like they report
that they're, they give overly optimistic uh prognoses uh
for their very ill patients in order for their
patients to have more hope. And so this is
really kind of a benevolent lie. Like the, the
doctors are lying for their own sake, they're lying
for the sake of their patients. Um And usually
they're not even outright lies. It's kind of like,
as we talked about before, we can minimize, we
can just not talk about certain things. And, um,
but when we look at, um, in, in, in
the field of sales, for example, what we find
is that, you know, lying or being dishonest, maybe
not lying, um, necessarily, but being dishonest is oftentimes,
uh, an important trait and it's actually valued by
employers, you know, and so, uh, if you're trying
to sell an inferior product at the same price
as a superior project, that's an impossible task if
you're being honest all the time. And so we
need to exaggerate advantages and minimize flaws and things
like that. And in, in politics, what we find
is that, you know, people, when we ask people,
what, in what fields are people more honest or
dishonest. People tend to, um, tend to list politics
as being uh a field in which people are
most dishonest. And there's some truth to that. Um,
POLITICIANS are placed in a difficult position of trying
to please a broad constituency where people have different,
uh goals and wants and needs. And so trying
to please everyone is difficult to do if you're
being honest all the time. But what we find
is that politicians, uh politics is in a field
is not a field where dishonest people, um enter
that field, the people who enter politics are just
as honest as, um any other person in the
general population. What we see is that once people
enter into politics, the pressures are put on them
where they find that they need to become dishonest.
And in fact, um, there's some research in Western
Europe showing that politicians who are willing to lie
are much more likely to be re-elected than politicians
who are unwilling to lie. So, uh, so it
might be that the field itself, um, molds people
into being big liars.
So it seems that at least in some uh
some prominent occupations, uh being dishonest, uh gets you
places. Right.
Absolutely.
So let me ask you about one particular topic
now. So people also sometimes lie in relationships but
particularly in romantic relationships. So why do people lie
in those cases specifically? I mean, what are their
motivations and what do they usually lie about
what they lie about? And their motivations probably depends
a lot on the, the phase of the relationship.
And so there's a lot of research on um
kind of the, the initial phases, the dating phase
of relationships. And um looking at online dating websites,
for example, both men and women tend to be
uh fairly dishonest when they're describing themselves, their attitudes,
their history. And essentially, you know, if we're on
the dating market, we're trying to make the best
case for ourselves. We, we're trying to market ourselves
and the way that we pull that off is
exaggerating positives and minimizing, minimizing negative traits. And so,
um for example, men know that women, uh, oftentimes
have a, a particular height standard that they're looking
for in prospective mates. And so men tend to
exaggerate how tall they are. They also tend to
exaggerate, um, the, the, the status or the, uh,
of their, uh, profession or the amount of income
they have and things like that and, and women
do the same thing just, uh, you know, they
lie about things that are being selected on, um,
by, by, um, people who are looking at them
as mates. Um Now once you get into established
relationships, um, the, you know, the, the, the tension
around, uh, uh uh those, um, types of traits
are probably much less. And so the topics that
people lie about start to differ. Um What we
find is that men and women in relationships do
lie to each other even in well established relationships.
But the, the lies tend to be focused on
maintaining uh peace and harmony in the relationship. And
so people will, will lie in order to prevent
a fight from emerging or, but they also lie
for benevolent reasons, um, to boost the sen the
sense of self esteem and their partners. Um And
so the, the lies tend to be more supportive
in nature, but certainly when people are doing bad
things in relationships, they'll lie about it. So, you
know, people lie about their Infidelities and, and, um,
you know, drug habits and things like that. Um
But again, you know, their, what their, what their
ultimate goal is, is to try to preserve their
relationship and they're using lies to make that happen.
But we've, we've studied lies within the context of
people's sexual relationships as well. And what we found
in those cases is that the, the majority of
the reasons that people are lying in the context
of their sex lives is to make their partners
feel better. So they, they feign enthusiasm and they,
they lie about the fact that they're, you know,
also thinking about other people and, and things like
that, but the, the goal that they, um are
trying to achieve, at least their self reported goal
is to try to make the experience more pleasant
for their partners.
And what about familial relationships and friendships? Because sometimes
people also lie in those contexts, right.
Yeah, absolutely. Um, WE, we see in, in adolescence,
for example, the people they lie to most is
their friends. We thought it'd be parents but it's
their, their friends. And, um, and when we look
at why they're lying, it's, it's oftentimes, you know,
getting back to this idea of they're trying to
save face, they're trying to present themselves as being,
you know, more desirable as, as uh friends than
perhaps they feel like they are. But when we
look at adult in adults, um people tend to
be pretty honest with their close friends. Um, YOU
know, all of us have this, uh, this, this
desire to present genuine versions of ourselves to people
who will accept us. And when we have those
close friendships with people, we tend to seek them
as the, the outlets where we'll be most honest
about who we are and what we're thinking and,
and our wants and desires and so forth.
Mhm. And I, I mean, talking, uh, a little
bit since we're talking about relationships, getting a little
bit into some of the negative aspects and consequences
of lying in this context. So what are the
ways by which social relationships get fractured by deception?
Well, you know, trust is, uh, is really, uh,
can be difficult to build and it takes time
to build like to us. Like if you just
imagine the person who you trust more than anyone
in the world, the reason you trust them is
they've established this very long track record of being
honest and, and being a, a trustworthy partner. Um,
BUT it's also very easy to fracture that trust.
You know, just one lie can, uh, undo all
of the, the trust that's been built up over
years, but we do treat lies differently. And so
not all lies are, are given the same moral
weight and, or ethical weight. And so when within
relationships, for example, if people find that someone has
told a white lie, they tend to overlook that
and it doesn't really damage the trust. However, if
someone is caught telling a selfish lie where they're
taking advantage of their close partner, then, then obviously
that's gonna fracture the trust and, uh, you know,
and, and in some cases, the, the trust is
fractured to such a degree that it's impossible to
rebuild. Um, IF we look at, you know, within
friendships, but we can also look more broadly at
trust. We can, we can see that the amount
of trust between people varies quite a bit from
one location to another, from one country to another
or one society to another. Um, uh, THERE'S a,
a book out that, uh, that covers, uh, distrust
within a small Romanian village where essentially no one
trusts each other. And it's, it's really remarkable how,
um, how different that, so that society operates when
you only can really count on a small handful
of people and everyone else is essentially viewed as
a danger or a threat. And so,
but by the way, by the way, just one
second, the book you're talking about is living with
distrust by Rabu Umbridge.
That's correct. That's correct. Yeah. Yeah,
I, I've had him on my show. So, yeah,
it's, it's, it sounded familiar.
Yeah. Yeah. So it's really remarkable when you read
about what it's like to live in a deeply
distrustful society compared to a trustful one. It's, uh,
it's much more challenging.
Yeah. And so, I mean, are there any specific
cases where perhaps people might need interventions to reduce
lying in relationships? And if so, are there those
kinds of interventions.
Yes. Uh There are people, I get emails from
people at least weekly um explaining that they're lying
or their partners lying or their children's lying is
causing massive problems within their relationships and they're asking
me for help. So there's, there's certainly people who
experience lying is out of control and in need
of some uh change. And uh I think fortunately
the, the um standard um tools that we have
for psychological intervention for other types of problems are
pretty um effective for helping people deal with lying,
standard cognitive behavior, therapies. For example, you know, a
lot of the reasons that people lie is um
because of how they're thinking about the world and,
and what they're seeing is there options for interacting
with people and we can help people cultivate tools
to find different strategies for getting the same things
they're trying to achieve.
So going, getting back to the big liars, I
would like to uh hear a little bit more
about, let's say they, their models operandi. So how
do they get away with their lies? Exactly. Do
they usually resort to particular strategies or tactics or
how, how do they go about it?
We've, we've interviewed a lot of people about their
strategies for lying. Um And it's pretty interesting because
we all have ideas about how liars behave. And
so when we ask uh people, you know, what,
what are liars look like? Like how can you
tell if someone's lying, they say, well, liars, avoid
eye contact and liars fidget a lot. And liars
touch their face and liars, stutter and stammer. But
when we ask liars how they tell convincing lies,
they essentially do the opposite of those things. They
say, I make eye contact. I try not to
fidget. I try not to stutter and stammer. Um
So those are some of the techniques that they
use is, um, is just to try to look
normal is what most of them say. And so
we have a, a sense of what our normal
behavior looks like. And so we can just try
to continue to engage in that normal looking behavior
when we're telling lies, another strategy that um the
big liars report using is to plan their lies.
So if they know that the topic is gonna
come up, they plan in advance what they're gonna
say. Um And they also plan the types of
details that they're gonna reveal and the ones they
won't reveal. And, and oftentimes a strategy, a strategy
that they use is to bury a lie within
a cloud of truth. So I can tell you
a story that is almost entirely truthful. And then
there's just this one lie and that makes it
difficult to detect when most of what I'm saying
is coherent and consistent with the information that you
already know. And so it appears truthful and then
I just hide that one lie within the midst
of it,
by the way, are people generally good at lie
detection?
No, they're not. They're actually pretty poor at lie
detection. Um And so the way that we study,
uh, you know, how good people are detecting lies
is we, we typically record videos of people who
are lying or telling the truth. And then we
show these videos to participants in our study and
we just ask them to identify who are the
liars and who are the people who are being
honest. And in a lot of these studies, half
of the videos are of liars and half of
them are telling the truth. And we find that
people are, their accuracy rates are around 54% where,
you know, you get 50% accuracy just flipping a
coin. And what this suggests is that people are
really, really poor lie detectors and in the, in
the cases where they do detect liars, it tends
to be because some people just aren't very good
liars. There are some people who, when they're telling
a lie, it's just kind of obvious. But those
are the minority of people, the vast majority of
people are, is concerned when they're lying or being
honest just by looking at their body language or
listening to their tone of speech and things like
that. So, so to answer your question, yeah, people
are not very good uh lie detecting and uh
as a person who studies lying, I'm aware of
that myself. Uh, IN my classes, we do activities
where people tell lies and tell the truth and
I'm no better than the average person. And we
actually see that in, uh, in, you know, professions
where people are, you know, part of their job
is to, to, to detect lying, like with police
interrogators and things like that. They are no better
than college students that watching these videos and figuring
out who's lying, who's telling the truth.
And so how are most lies detected when they
are detected? I mean, what makes for uh what,
what leads to someone really uncovering a lie? Usually,
you know, the, the primary way in the, in
the way we study this is we just ask
people like think of the last time you detected
that someone was lying. How did you figure it
out? Um What we find is that almost no
one says, oh, they fidgeted or they weren't making
eye contact, what they, what they talk about is
evidence that they uncovered. So they say, oh, this
person said something, it was inconsistent with this other
fact that I already knew about or they'll report
that they had third party information. So my, you
know, my romantic partner said they were at this
party, but I talked to people with the who
were at the party and they said, you know,
my romantic partner wasn't there at all. And so,
so that's how people tend to discover lies that
um most lies go undiscovered. Uh When we ask
people about their lying and we ask them what
proportion of your lies get discovered. They say it's
a very, very small minority of lies that get
discovered. I think part of that is we don't
really care if someone tells me if I say,
how are you doing? And they say I'm doing
fine. I don't really care if they're not doing
fine. I mean, in, in the sense where I'm
gonna try and dig deeper and find out if
they're lying. It's only in really consequential situations where
we realize someone's motivations might be at odds with
ours. And the outcome of them being honest versus
dishonest has um uh a, a deeply profound effect
on me. In those cases, I'll start digging and
looking for additional information and, and even trying to
solicit confessions and things like that. Um So, uh
that's, that tends to be how we uncover lying
is by digging deeper.
And two big liars themselves use particular strategies to
avoid detection.
Yeah. What we find is that the people who
are good liars tend to be really good actors
that is they can feign emotions very well. Um
And they, they are also very good at controlling
details and so they're very um selective and how
they present information. Um BUT they tend to present
themselves as friendly, confident, engaged with the person who
they're talking to and they concoct when they do
concoct lies, the lies tend to be very plausible
and they present them in a way where they
found where they sound very certain.
And so, uh, earlier when we talked about relationships,
I, I asked you what sort of, uh, consequences
might lying have on different kinds of social relationships.
What about the effects that big liars can, there
can have both on themselves and on society more
generally?
Well, when we, um, look at the effect it
has on themselves and we, when we talk to
people, uh like pathological liars, like they feel awful
like they, they come to us and, and, and
want help because they feel like their lives are
unfolding or they feel like they just, uh you
know, can't be genuine with anyone anymore. And so
there's, you know, some pretty good evidence that when
people lie a lot, they, they actually have neg
negative outcomes for themselves in a lot of ways.
But, you know, when we look at, um, you
know, the effects that big liars have on society
more broadly, you know, they, they, you know, lying
in other forms of uh dishonesty lead to, you
know, billions of dollars and fraud every year. And
so there's this massive societal consequence and, you know,
even when we look at politics, you know, when
people, um, um you know, develop this deep mistrust
for politicians that it, you know, gravely alter society
in a lot of ways. And so, so, yeah,
uh you know, certainly lying can affect the individual,
but the consequence of the lying permeates out into
society and causes all sorts of mayhem.
Uh And so we've been referring to pathological liars
throughout our conversation, but what characterizes them? Exactly. And
I mean, is this some sort of a clinical
diagnosis or not?
So, yeah, we wrote a book that was published
last year on a pathological lying and the, the
reason we, and I'm talking about when I say
we uh my colleague uh Drew Curtis and I
um have been doing a lot of this research
on pathological lying. And we're interested in that because
it's a topic that is, you know, familiar in
our vernacular. We talk about pathological lying all the
time when we use the term people seem to
know what we mean. But um there hadn't been
any consistent research on this topic. The first people
that the first researchers that looked at pathological lying
were doing research on it over 100 years ago.
Um But there hasn't been a consistent definition of
what the term means. And so in our review
of the literature, we found 17 different definitions of
pathological lying that have been used over the decades
and there's a lot of inconsistency. Um And so
when we started talking about pathological lying, we started
thinking of it in the, the context of the
way that we um identify other mental health disorders.
So, pathology or psychopathology like anxiety disorders and mood
disorders like depression. When we're talking about those, we
tend to um think of the, the person as
um having some uh adjustment problems in their relationships
or in the workplace. They're also experiencing discomfort and
distress around this, this problem that they're having. Um
AND of oftentimes the disorder puts them at some
sort of risk, uh you know, um sometimes it's
risk of, of injury or death and sometimes it's
risk of like incarceration and things like that. And
so when we started thinking about pathological lying, we
put it in that framework. So we talked about,
we define pathological lying as um a a pattern
of excessive lying. That's oftentimes compulsive in nature, it
causes disruption in people's lives, it causes them to
experience distress and oftentimes puts them at, at risk.
Uh But I mean, in terms of, let's say
disease classification, is there any category specific category for
this kind of uh behavior that does it have
any specific name or term in, for example, the
DS M or, or, or elsewhere?
Yeah. So in the United States, we use the
DS M or the diagnostic and statistical manual of
the American Psychiatric Association. And that's basically the, the
book in which every recognized mental health disorder is
listed along with the diagnostic criteria. And pathological lying
isn't listed as a um a diagnosis in, in
that manual. Um IT'S listed as a, as a,
a symptom of a few disorders, but uh like
personality disorders. Uh FOR example, but, but not as
a disorder in and of itself. So my colleague
Drew Curtis is currently doing a lot of work
to more better represent pathological lying. And he's doing
some good work showing that some people exhibit pathological
lying in the absence of any mental health disorder,
any other mental health diagnosis which suggests maybe it
is a stand alone condition and should be recognized
as a stand alone um diagnosis.
Mhm. And, and I mean, if it would be
recognized as a stand alone diagnosis, would you have,
for example, a set of criteria for diagnosing someone
as a pathological liar?
Yeah. So uh and we're, we're working on some
diagnostic tools right now. So we have a uh
uh a diagnostic self report measure um that uh
is about to be published right now. It's under
review at a journal. And um and so we've
done a lot of work validating it showing that
people who seem to meet these criteria that we've
set out for pathological lying have poorer life outcomes,
like they're more likely to have problems in their
relationships, problems at work and so forth. They also
um report higher levels of emotional distress on these
different psychological measures that we've used to validate it.
They also have this lifelong pattern of pathological lying.
So the lying isn't just a, a response to
a specific event in their life. And so, yeah,
there does seem to be some consistency with the
way that we're defining it and the uh the,
the symptoms and outcomes of these pathological liars are
exhibiting.
But in this particular case, since you're labeling it,
pathological lying, should we assume that people would have
this condition when it's classified as a condition that
they have no control over it, that they basically
cannot help themselves if they don't get any sort
of treatment or something like that.
YOU know, that's that, that kind of gets down
to, you know, deeper questions around free will and
things like that. So to say that someone has
no control over something I think is a, a
bit of a stretch like we have control over,
you know, most things in our lives, but the,
the difficulty we face controlling things like as someone
who is uh uh addicted to smoking cigarettes, they,
they have control but they find that control very
challenging. And so I think the goal that we
have as psychologists is to offer people who are
having difficulties controlling um coping mechanisms and strategies to
help them better control uh those behaviors that they're
trying to reduce.
Uh And if this turns out to be a
condition in and of itself, uh do you expect
it to uh uh do you expect that we
will be able to treat it somehow? I mean,
are there, for example, already any tools at our
disposal to deal with other conditions where perhaps some
of them might even have pathological lying as one
of the criteria for diagnosis that would also or
could also apply here.
Yeah, I believe so. And I, I mentioned earlier
in our conversation, um, cognitive behavior therapy has, has
demonstrated some effectiveness. And so essentially what we're doing
with that therapy is we're helping people change their
beliefs and their attitudes about things that are going
on in their lives and the hope that those
changes and beliefs will lead to changes in behavior.
There's also some evidence that um you know, some
pharmaceutical treatments might be effective um to help with
like kind of compulsive behaviors um and anxiety as
well. But all of this research is very, very
preliminary. And so, uh my colleague, Doctor Curtis is,
is uh starting to do some work trying to
validate some of these treatments, but it's difficult because
in order to, to carry out these days, you
have to find a large enough group of pathological
liars. And so it's pretty a pretty slow process.
But, you know, we do have people um coming
through his laboratory that uh we're beginning some of
this research on.
So let me just ask you one last question
earlier, we mentioned here how people usually are not
very good at lie detection, but are there perhaps
some scientifically validated ways that people can avoid being
by liars? I mean, at least perhaps some things
that people try to might try to pay attention
to some strategies that they might use, like, for
example, I'm not asking people particular things or paying
attention to this or that, I mean, is there
something like that or not?
Yeah. Um I think the, the principal technique is
to, or the principal strategy is just to recognize
when another person's motives are in conflict with your
own. And that's when we tend to see dishonesty
um occurring. And so just recognizing when that's happening
is important, um but then we can also use
strategies uh that include digging deeper for information. And
so uh one strategy I use, I I, I'm
a professor, so I have students lying to me
all the time. And so I'll ask them for
more details about their story and sometimes they'll, you
know, report details that are in conflict with something
I already know, or they'll report details that are
in conflict with something they've previously stated. And then
another strategy is to have people retell stories. And
sometimes if it's a fabricated story, when they retell
it, the details will change. Um But primarily what,
what I look for is uh inconsistencies and when
you see inconsistencies, that's when you, you know, you
might wanna dig a bit deeper. Um AND then
sometimes, uh you know, just asking for honesty is
effective, you know, if we suspect someone is being
dishonest, just simply uh soliciting a confession saying, like,
look, I know that this is a hard thing
to talk about but it's really important for me
that we have an honest conversation here. Can you
just give me the honest answer? And I'll accept
that uh what we find is that a lot
of people will just confess at that point. And
so really checking facts though is the, is the,
the key way. There's no uh secret uh technique
that you know, that, you know, Sherlock Holmes uses
other than looking for the evidence. And so, so
that's what we focus on.
Great. So, Doctor Hart, let's send on that note
then and just to mention the books again, the
latest one, big liars, what psychological science tells us
about lying and how you can avoid being duped.
And the other one, pathological lying theory, research and
practice. I'm leaving links to them in the description
box of this interview. And apart from the books,
would you like also to tell people where they
can find you and your work on the internet?
Uh They can uh find me at my uh
my website um at Christian O heart.com and uh
and then on my academic website. Um But uh
yeah, thanks so much for having me on the
show. I've really enjoyed the conversation. It's been a
great time.
Ok, thank you so much for coming on the
show. It's been a pleasure to talk to you.
All right, thanks. Joy. Enjoyed the conversation. It's been
a great time.
Ok. Thank you so much for coming on the
show. It's been a pleasure to talk to you.
All right, thanks. Hi guys. Thank you for watching
this interview. Until the end. If you liked it,
please share it. Leave a like and hit the
subscription button. The show is brought to you by
the N Lights learning and development. Then differently check
the website at N lights.com and also please consider
supporting the show on Patreon or paypal. I would
also like to give a huge thank you to
my main patrons and paypal supporters, Perera Larson, Jerry
Muller and Frederick Suno Bernard Seche O of Alex
Adam Castle Matthew Whitten Bear. No wolf, Tim Ho
Erica LJ Connors, Philip Forrest Connolly. Then the Met
Robert Wine in NAI Z Mark Nevs calling Hol
Brookfield, Governor Mikel Stormer Samuel Andre Francis for Agns
Ferus and H her meal and Lain Jung Y
and the Samuel K Hes Mark. Smith J Tom
Hummel s Friends. David Sloan Wilson. Ya dear, Roman
Roach Diego, Jan Punter, Romani Charlotte, Bli Nico Barba,
Adam Hunt, Pavlo Stassi na Me, Gary G Alman
Sam of Zed YPJ Barboa, Julian Price Edward Hall,
Eden Broner Douglas Fry Franca, Beto Lati Cortez Solis
Scott Zachary FTD and W Daniel Friedman, William Buckner,
Paul Giorgio, Luke Loki, Georgio, Theophano, Chris Williams and
Peter Wo David Williams, the Ausa Anton Erickson Charles
Murray, Alex Shaw, Marie Martinez, Coralie Chevalier, Bangalore, Larry
Dey Junior, Old Ebon Starry Michael Bailey. Then spur
by Robert Grassy Zorn, Jeff mcmahon, Jake. Zul Barnabas
Radis Mark Kemple Thomas Dvor. Luke Neeson, Chris to
Kimberley Johnson. Benjamin Gilbert Jessica. No, Linda Brendan, Nicholas
Carlson, Ismael Bensley Man, George Katis, Valentine Steinman, Perras,
Kate Van Goler, Alexander Abert Liam Dan Biar Masoud
Ali Mohammadi Perpendicular Jer Urla. Good enough, Gregory Hastings
David Pins of Sean Nelson, Mike Levin and Jos
Net. A special thanks to my producers is our
web, Jim Frank Luca Stina, Tom Veg and Bernard
N Cortes Dixon, Bendik Muller Thomas Trumble, Catherine and
Patrick Tobin, John Carlman, Negro, Nick Ortiz and Nick
Golden. And to my executive producers, Matthew Lavender, Sergi,
Adrian Bogdan Knits and Rosie. Thank you for all.